el ministro de gobierno Henry cucalon
dijo que el ejecutivo ha cumplido en un
90% con lo pactado pero ustedes dicen
que no Cuáles son los acuerdos a los que
llegaron y que no se están cumpliendo
bien efectivamente
un 10% de avance de acuerdo al análisis
que hemos hecho de los acuerdos que se
había establecido esto ha sido analizado
el día de ayer en la asamblea de la
conaya pues y realmente la reacción de
las bases puede indignación por la falta
de compromiso por no cumplir con su
palabra por parte del presidente de la
república y los carteras de estado y por
tanto pues al ver el foco o casi escaso
cumplimiento de los mismos acuerdos se
decidió pues retirarse y romper el
diálogo con el gobierno nacional pero
cuando ustedes dicen que hay acuerdos
que no se han cumplido A qué acuerdo se
refieren
Perdón no se puede escuchar
Disculpe si quiere Le repito la pregunta
ustedes dicen que hay acuerdos que no se
han cumplido A qué acuerdo se refieren
bueno es la gran Maya de todo en el caso
de la Manía el tema más sensibles del
tema extractivo y en este sentido pues
ahí también vemos un cumplimiento total
Más bien una avanzada por parte del
gobierno en la política de extracción
minera a través de políticas que
prácticamente en los últimos días han
amenazado los territorios ancestrales
con la implantación de minería metálica
esto quiere decir que al contrario de
cumplirlo más bien está contraviniendo
los mismos acuerdos Y por tanto eso es
lo que ha motivado el rechazo de las
bases pues y la ruptura del proceso de
diálogo en estos momentos cuáles son sus
principales demandas
bueno por un lado que se va a seguir con
la agenda de los diez puntos los diez
puntos constituyen un programa mínimo
que responde a las necesidades del
pueblo ecuatoriano Más allá de que el
diálogo no haya avanzado en nosotros
continuaremos exigiendo Pues el
cumplimiento de los mismos Pero por otro
lado en la parte política hay una
situación de total inestabilidad de
falta de gobernabilidad y pues de falta
de credibilidad por parte del presidente
de la república Y es por eso que otra de
las resoluciones de la asamblea de la
conaya fue precisamente que el
presidente de la República en estos
momentos debe dar un paso al costado y
más bien la asamblea nacional debe
proceder con el juicio político para su
gestión el 8 de marzo ustedes convocaron
a una huelga general Cómo esperan que se
desarrolle la jornada y cuál es el
principal objetivo
bueno no está definido una jornada de
paro todavía son movilizaciones
preventivas que se lo Está realizando
pero lógicamente al conmemorarse un día
tan importante como es el Día
Internacional de la mujer Pues también
los movilizaremos de igual manera en
Solidaridad con el pueblo hermano del
Perú que está siendo masacrado durante
más de 70 días Por tanto se ha decidido
que también esta sea una fecha
emblemática y por qué Por tanto
delegaciones de los distintos
territorios de pueblos y nacionalidades
también puedan movilizarse en la ciudad
de Quito pues para expresar su rechazo
ante la falta de cumplimiento de los
acuerdos pero también de rechazo a la
política que está llevando adelante el
presidente de la república